this is my first event on the red carpet
so I'm excited oh I do remember this
oh
no please don't make me listen to myself
what am I wearing what is that necklace
look at my hair and makeup looks so bad
I'm supporting my baby tonight that's
David that was my first boyfriend hi
David Gallagher how are you
I liked him very much very sweet boy
let's talk about David I'm actually I've
been pretty picky about my roles I don't
want to get you know Typecast into
anything so oh I'm really picky about my
rolls I don't want to get Typecast
to 15 years later I mean what I still
talk like that which is the scary thing
I haven't grown up like at all I don't
sound more mature or womanly at all
right
it's it's weird to see when I was so
much younger I because I've grown so
much as a person
I would think that I would listen to
myself talk and be like God who's that
but I sound so similar in the sentiments
that I'm expressing and sometimes I'm
surprised by how eccentric I am and then
I'm also surprised at how deep I always
was even as a young young kid you know
just keep smiling and don't let what
people say get you down Megan was
nothing but smiles thin eyebrows green
eyeshadow and hair in curls of the 2004
premiere of Confessions of a Teenage
Drama Queen the then 17 year old starred
alongside Lindsay Lohan as her number
one enemy oh she's crying the baby the
following year E.T was with Megan onset
of the comedy hope and fate where she
eventually met her future husband Brian
Austin Green and action Brian who was 13
years her senior made a guest appearance
on the sitcom and according to Megan
there was an instant connection yeah I
just was kind of in love with him right
away and he did this thing where he came
to the dressing room and he like gave
his number out to everyone in case
anyone needed to call him at some point
but he gave it he was giving it to me
like I knew he was giving me his number
and my sister was with me and she was
like you're not going to be anything but
a booty call and this is our 10th year
of marriage and our 15th year together
so
I'm nobody's booty call okay
okay on again off again relationship for
years eventually tying them out in 2010
as for her career I can't believe it I'm
here right now
her big break came in 2007 starring
alongside Shia LaBeouf in Transformers a
lot of you don't know about her let me
let me walk you through it audience
she's big into Nirvana she's got like 40
dogs
you do it like 40 dogs seven dogs seven
dogs is still a bundle nobody cares well
let's talk about the movie it looks like
you're at your distributor Cap's a
little
yeah how'd you know that
uh my dad he was a he was a real Grease
Monkey it's a really overwhelming
experience because I was on a TV show I
was on a sitcom where I barely you know
did did anything I had two lines a week
so to go from that to being a lead
character in this movie is crazy because
it's the biggest movie of this summer
and uh I think it's important for female
characters to be represented uh as
strong women as well as well as I mean
it's fine to be a damsel in distress too
but it's nice to see an action movie
with a girl that can kick a little ass
so you bust into the crowd over there
what's that what's that energy like when
you approach them
um they're all really enthusiastic and
they're really sweet and genuine and I
mean it's amazing it's a Good Feeling by
2009 the rising star had two films in
the works a Transformer Sequel and
Jennifer's Body I am a god you you're
playing a demon who eats men how much
fun was that for you uh it was a lot of
fun I mean the characters are kind of
really insane and uh she's just really
inappropriate so I enjoy that a lot it's
similar to myself over the next few
years Megan went on to star in several
movies including Jonah Hex friends with
kids and this is 40. you have an amazing
body really
yes I think just the perception when
you're when you're a child and if you're
30 or 40 you associate it with your
parents and you always saw them as being
like Dowdy or not fun or so it's
interesting to be an adult and to
realize because my husband's 39 he's
almost 40. and you can still be you know
young and vibrant and
sexy and all of those things yup life
was good for Megan she and the 90210
Alum welcomed their first son together
that same year on Baby Noah that's so
funny to hear isn't it in a press line
yeah we never call him by his name we
just call him baby the working Mama
continued to kill it at the box office
despite an ongoing feud with
Transformers director Michael Bay the
two put their differences aside in 2014
for another big franchise hit Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles it's all happening
and I'm very excited it's her it's her
guys it's her horse it's her Donnie when
I shot this I was I only had Noah and I
got pregnant on this movie so at the
time I was just working and Brian was
taking care of Noah and I was growing
Bodhi these four have done more for this
city than you will ever know I think we
all knew there was going to be a sequel
because it's just a property that is
already people love it it already has
like such a huge audience that we would
have had to really have destroyed it for
people to not uh gone in 2015 Megan's
personal life hit a rough patch she and
Brian announced their separation with
Megan filing for divorce but by August
of 2016 the hot and cold couple welcomed
their third son Journey I'm definitely
not a workaholic and I feel like I'm at
home with my kids a lot I it's not so I
don't have a crazy life I don't have a
crazy schedule in 2019 Megan filed to
dismiss the divorce from Brian only to
break up once again less than a year
later the mom of three then sparked
romance rumors with Machine Gun Kelly
who she met on set of midnight in the
switchgrass she then went on to star in
his music video
working with him is amazing honestly I
don't know if people understand what a
good actor he is he's so charismatic and
so naturally addicted and he's so
intense her next project till death a
thriller about an unhappy married couple
what is your advice on not being in a
toxic relationship what is your advice
on being in a non-relationship that
reflects uh till death you know
um I think you just have to be aligned
with
yourself and you have to remove your ego
as much as possible you have to be
selfless meaning you have to always
prioritize loving the other person where
they are as they are who they are in
this moment not try to change people
Megan was officially a single woman
early in 2022 after finalizing her
divorce from Brian and her Whirlwind
romance with MGK kicked up a notch we're
talking matching manicures a blood vowel
necklace and lots of PDA well it's just
hard to be away from someone that you
love and I think it's important to
maintain Intimacy in a relationship in
the distance it's very even with
facetimes or things like that it's
difficult to maintain a really deep
level of Engagement with a partner and
so I try to be there as much as I can I
won't be able to be on the whole tour
but I try to be present it was like
you're gonna be naked tonight and I was
like whatever you say Daddy whatever
daddy says the twin flames who got
engaged after dating for a year and a
half have been Inseparable even teaming
up on a couple of projects this past
year
you must be so proud Megan
super proud yeah how much fun was it to
be directed by your man
um I mean he was amazing and he wrote
the whole movie in like three days which
is incredible he gets these bursts of
creativity where he sort of downloads
something from the universe and puts out
an amazing product really quickly
[Music]
thank you